The first thing we want to share
with you is the number one piece of
feedback we get from new
students in the program.
And that's that these classes
can be really, really difficult.
And many students come to this program
from other online experiences like MOOCs
or other online programs.
And they're surprised to see how
difficult these classes can be.
But these are real Georgia Tech classes
taught by the same instructors,
graded by the same graders,
and using the same tests and
assessments as any class on campus.
So they can be very difficult.
So towards that end, one thing we
recommend is that your first semester in
the program, take only one class.
That first semester, you're going to
be learning about being in the program
as you are learning
the material of that class.
So take only one class in order
to set yourself up for success.